[Music]  the nominees for outstanding achievement  and sound effects editing are okay wait  I'm sorry okay I know we're not supposed  to make political speeches during the  Oscars but someone must speak for those  who cannot speak throughout at 70 years  the Academy Awards have focused only on  the achievements of people like people  are so good the Academy has overlooked  and besmirched oh yes I said besmirched  the contributions that animals have made  to motion pictures and I'm going to do  something about it right now yes people  ladies and gentlemen the star of eleven  motion pictures including clan of the  cave bear legends of the fall and most  recently the edge bark the bear  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  haha I just soiled myself